[Music]
on this friday night the wife of the
nova scotia mass shooter shares her
story what lisa banfield says she knew
he put the bed to my neck and why she
didn't tell police before it was too
late he said if any please come up
shooting
memories flooding back how families of
the air india bombing victims are
reacting to the assassination of a
polarizing figure it basically opens up
the wounds which had developed a little
bit of his car over time
wildfire deja vu i lost everything down
there last year another nightmare for
linton bc as a blaze quickly spreads
near the already fire ravaged community
plus lost at sea
the amazing survival story of a man who
says he owes his life to a kid's toy
[Music]
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight mithu gancia good
evening and thanks for joining us nova
scotia's mass casualty commission heard
from a long-awaited witness today lisa
banfield the common law spouse of the
gunman responsible for the 2020
port-a-pick shooting spoke publicly for
the first time during her emotional
multi-hour testimony she confessed about
lying to police but stressed she did so
because she was scared for her safety
our callum smith was at the proceedings
today and has tonight's top story
the inquiry hearing publicly from the
gunman's spouse of 19 years lisa
banfield questions better knowledge of
gabriel wartman's police paraphernalia
and replica rcmp cruiser banfield said
he collected random things but she never
thought he would hurt anyone asked why
she didn't report his illegal firearms
to police he had the handgun by the
nightstand and he said if any please
come up shooting
so when they asked me that i didn't want
them to go in because i didn't want them
to get hurt
banfield says the gunman controlled her
and physically assaulted her on several
occasions over the years it was a couple
times that he um
if we had a fight
he put the bag to my left
um to scare me
and said that he could blow off my head
so i was scared i'm not gonna
i'm sorry i'm not gonna say anything
but victims families had high hopes to
learn from banfield's testimony my big
question would be
why
would he have targeted my brother who
was so far out of the way all i know is
that the perpetrator knew my stepfather
the rest of it is just
a show to me
i'm tired of fighting two and a half
years into this
when this started we thought we could
all sit back and just let
an independent group do it but it's not
independent patterson law represents the
families of 14 victims they haven't been
able to directly cross-examine banfield
due to the inquiry's trauma-informed
approach lawyer michael scott says they
wanted more details about april 18th and
19th 2020 when 22 people lost their
lives i don't know if miss banfield is
lying i don't know if miss banfield is
telling the truth i don't know if miss
banfield is mistaken
because we don't have an opportunity to
ask her any questions they walked out
before proceedings finished thankful for
family support banfield says there were
gaps in services she received after the
rampage it's hard for me to say this
because i know i'm here and my family's
here and there's so many people that
aren't here
so i don't want to complain about what i
don't have
the inquiry resumes next week callum
smith global news halifax
we are learning more tonight about the
brazen daytime murder of ripu damon
singh malik the 75 year old was gunned
down yesterday in a busy commercial
complex in surrey british columbia malik
was a deeply polarizing figure best
known as one of two men acquitted in the
deadly 1985 air india terrorist bombings
erin mcarthur has the latest on the
investigation including what police are
focusing on right now
the police investigation now focused on
the people inside this white honda
the suv was spotted on cctv shortly
after shots were fired and was found
burning several blocks away
bc's integrated homicide investigation
team looking for witnesses to come
forward to help identify the shooters it
is a white honda crv
it arrived about 7 am
and the occupants were waiting for mr
mallet
malik courted controversy for more than
three decades
immigrating to canada in the 1970s he is
most widely known as one of the key
suspects in the bombing of air india
flight 182 and an explosion at tokyo's
narita airport in 1985. although the
allegations were never proven in court
there are still questions swirling about
his role in the terror plot that killed
331 people to this day we have not
brought people to justice
i do not doubt for a moment
mr malik knew more
and as i've said that is perhaps the
biggest
frustration for me
is he is a man who has died who has been
killed but he has left with his secrets
while malek was associated with sick
extremism he also worked as a successful
businessman and philanthropist his
family remained adamant he be remembered
for his work in the community and not
for his potential involvement in
canada's worst mass murder the bigger
part of his life was
his community his family
and the legacy he's left with
khalsa schools cultural credit union
five kids eight grandkids
and that's his that's his legacy
while the rcmp are confident this murder
was targeted there are questions about
why malik was gunned down
journalist gupt singh isn't convinced it
has to do with air india we need to look
into all possibilities
investigators need to keep their mind
open
we cannot 100 say that he has been
killed by
a certain group of people
putiman singh malik was 75 years old
the investigation into his death still
in its infancy
erin macarthur global news
the air india bombings remain the
largest mass killing in canada's history
331 people were killed including 268
canadians families who lost loved ones
in the terrorist attack say malik's
death won't bring them any closure mike
trolley reports
the victims families have waited and
suffered for 37 years in their quest for
answers
[Music]
singh malik was acquitted in the bombing
of air india flight 182 but remained a
divisive figure in the south asian
community
now with malik's death deepak
condelwall's faint hope for justice has
dimmed even more
you know his death
however it came by
does take a lot more of the secrets that
he had to the grave and which we will
never know about khandelwal visits one
of air india's two toronto memorials
every year and thinks often of his two
sisters a chandra who is 21 and manju
just 19 and the promise of a future
pharmacist and med student lost
i lost my wife
of over 20 years
dr bal gupta appeared frequently during
the air india inquiry it's an
understatement to say that 37 years
since the plane went down have been hard
it's basically opens up the wounds which
had
developed a little bit of his car over
time he hasn't thought of malik often
preferring instead the memory of his
late wife ramwathi but he says
regardless what anybody thought of malik
his murder is injustice
even though mr malik was a suspect
prime suspect in air india tragedy
i my sympathies for a children
the children are
suffering the same
feelings
grief
which
i and my children felt
when my wife was taken away
by an act of terrorism the air india
bombing has defined the lives of many of
the survivors and decades of court cases
and inquiries have taken their toll
kandel has the added burden of knowing
he was supposed to be on that flight you
think about it every day
uh it never does go away people always
ask is there closure there never really
is closure
and you know you get triggers like what
happened yesterday that continue to kind
of put your system in shock she was the
third year pharmacy student u of s he
doesn't expect that you have a second
here to ever change mike delay global
news toronto
nearly one year after the thalabon
seized control of afghanistan the
canadian government's special
immigration program for afghans is
nearing capacity many of those who
cooperated with canadian forces and
eight agencies remain in hiding looking
for a way out of the country and out of
danger as abigail beeman reports
advocates and those with families still
in that country are calling on ottawa to
do more to get people out
i'm feeling guilty because you know i'm
safe here in canada
but because of me my family is at risk
this afghan-canadian human rights
activist has been pressing the canadian
government about her six family members
still in afghanistan for nearly a year
we had to just um put them on fire
and bury whatever we could but then uh
you know to just destroy the entire
documents that we had
from our work um so
it's a you know it's constantly a fear
they are living in fear we've agreed to
conceal her identity because her family
is living under threat of the taliban
they applied to be part of canada's
special immigration program for people
with a lasting connection to canada such
as interpreters former employees and
their families they filled out lengthy
paperwork but still haven't had anything
but auto responses from the immigration
department i feel betrayed to be honest
extremely disappointed the program
opened a year ago and promised to accept
18 000 people now the immigration
minister's office is trying to push back
on reports it's closing the government
of canada has not closed the special
immigration program of 18 000 spots
available through the program we have
received over fifteen thousand
applications ircc continues to send out
invitations to apply to additional
referrals but the government concedes
there's enough interest to surpass the
eighteen thousand number and there are
only eighteen thousand spots to suggest
that the program is still open when all
the spots are spoken for the eighteen
thousand spots are spoken for they are
lying to themselves and they're lying to
the public we shouldn't give up we
should still push for an extension
lauren oates is calling for a 12-month
extension and double the number of spots
she has 17 staff members still in
afghanistan who have heard nothing from
the government they're at high risk they
all worked on programs funded by global
affairs canada by the canadian
government and they all submitted their
inquiries to the special immigration
measures program
from sometime between late july and
mid-august of last year it's a shameful
period for us
and i have to say regretfully that i
feel the government has handled the
entire file
very badly it's taken too long we've
left people waiting we don't provide
information and there's really no excuse
for that
so many people left waiting their
family's lives in the balance
abigail beeman global news ottawa
more monkey pox patients are popping up
across canada mirroring the rise in
cases seen globally canada has confirmed
nearly 500 cases since the virus emerged
as part of an unusual outbreak in may
but between july 4th and 13th cases
spiked to more than 170
a 59 percent increase in just a week as
jamie morocco reports experts say it is
time for all canadians to know the signs
and be vigilant
monkey box first presents with symptoms
similar to the flu fever headaches
swollen lymph nodes but there is a
distinct sign that sets it apart these
skin lesions indicators doctors say the
public needs to start recognizing we
need to increase our efforts if you will
to
you know nationally to get this under
control quebec continues to have the
largest number of cases saskatchewan
recorded its first patient thursday and
both bc and ontario are seeing increases
there are now more than ten thousand
cases worldwide everything i touch has
to stay in this room haran tolani was
hospitalized in the uk for what he says
was a severe bout of monkey pox the
lesion started on my nose only i didn't
have any lesions
until i got into the hospital a couple
of days after that the lesions appeared
on my hands
and on my feet confirmed cases of monkey
pox have largely been detected in men in
montreal toronto and vancouver
vaccination clinics have been offered to
communities at heightened risk
globally there have been shortages of
the shot including in the u.s which has
seen soaring demand in new york city and
california the white house announced an
order of 1.1 million doses here
officials have been tight-lipped about
supply and although ontario confirmed
its first female patient this week
experts say it's not time yet to mass
vaccinate it's also making sure people
understand there might be a behavioral
changes or certain activities that
people should be aware of that would put
them at greater risk it really requires
a certain type of a close intimate
contact physical contact from someone
who is infected with monkey pox a virus
the world health organization is
actively assessing to determine whether
to declare it of greater global concern
jamie morocco global news toronto
the scramble for safety in a town
already ravaged by wildfire coming up
the emotional evacuations as people are
once again forced to flee a growing
blaze near linton bc
just over a year ago most of the town of
litton in british columbia's fraser
canyon burnt to the ground when a huge
fast-moving wildfire swept through now
the area's remaining residents are again
being evacuated as another fire is
raging global's kamel kermali has the
latest from near litton kamil
nithu the fire continues to rage on now
four times larger than it was 24 hours
ago where we are right now is a linton
first nation reserve and you can see
behind me here how close the fire has
gotten to some of these homes and some
people here say they're not leaving
until the fire is right at their
doorstep meanwhile further west people
have already been affected by these
fires and lost their homes and have had
to come here to stay with family oh i
heard our home
and my brothers as a
burnt
gone
how does that make you feel knowing that
what do you think
everything's gone our whole livelihood
it's horrifying i'm just glad they all
made it out
it was a close it was a close call
yeah they said when they're just leaving
their home the flames were
in the back
behind the house
linton first nation has issued an
evacuation order for some of its
reserves it says the number of
structures lost to the fire has jumped
from three this morning to now sitting
in the double digits the regional
district here says an additional two
dozen homes have also been evacuated so
far the fire has stayed away from litten
itself which is east across the river
from this fire instead it's moving north
driven by strong winds today we're
expecting another low to move in and
bring winds 40 to 50 kilometers an hour
gusting 60. so the wind will continue to
be a challenge today as well the terrain
is really steep and poses a dangerous
activity to firefighters evacuees have
been sent north to the town of lilluet
to an evacuation shelter and some are
staying in the surrounding hotels but
space is running out fast leaving people
wondering where they'll go next nitu
kamil kermali reporting near linton bc
thanks kamil next a thorny visit how the
u.s president's historic trip to saudi
arabia sparked backlash
with his domestic agenda on the rocks
u.s president joe biden made a historic
journey today aboard air force one
flying direct from israel to saudi
arabia but that symbolic gesture
overshadowed by criticism over biden's
willingness to overlook saudi arabia's
human rights record and how desperately
biden needs cooperation from around the
region on a number of key issues jackson
proskow reports
for president joe biden each step of
this trip involves walking a political
and diplomatic tightrope from a fist
bump with the man accused of approving
the murder of jamal khashoggi to close
door meetings over a long list of mutual
concerns but the basic most elemental
thing is to send a message that america
is not pivoting to other parts of the
world that we're still sticking around
it's not that easy as a presidential
candidate biden declared saudi arabia a
pariah state and was reluctant to engage
with crown prince mohammed bin salman at
all
as president he now needs the saudis to
increase oil production as he faces a
political crisis at home over gas prices
and inflation biden insists he did not
waiver and raised khashoggi's murder
with the saudis before any other
business he basically said that he
he was not personally responsible for it
i indicated i thought he was
the four-day trip signals a larger shift
in middle east dynamics biden became the
first american president to fly directly
to saudi arabia from israel at a time
when he's hoping to unite two former
adversaries to confront a common threat
in iran biden's trip to the region also
included a visit to the west bank where
he met palestinian leaders and
reaffirmed support for a two-state
solution eventually even if the ground
is not ripe at this moment
to restart negotiations
the united states and my administration
will not give up on trying to bring the
palestinians israelis
and both sides closer together it's in
saudi arabia where biden is looking for
the biggest gains and facing the most
peril a delicate visit with a tenuous
ally
jackson prosko global news washington
firefighters and rescue teams searching
the wreckage of a number of buildings in
the ukrainian city of mikolav after
another round of russian missile strikes
[Applause]
ukrainian defense officials say 10
buildings were hit at least four people
were hurt in the early morning attacks
but firefighters managed to rescue a
puppy from the badly damaged building
the ukrainian government says their
recapture of snake island is allowing
for cargo ships carrying grain to enter
the black sea video posted by the
ukraine state border service shows cargo
ships being escorted by coast guard
vessels down the danube river to be
loaded with grain ukraine says 16 ships
have already started their journeys
while more than 90 others are waiting
their turn
coming up a man survives 18 hours lost
at sea thanks to an assist from an
unlikely flotation device
a tourist in greece is sharing an
amazing story of survival after he was
swept out to sea
the man identified only as ivan from
macedonia was swimming in the sea with
two friends when they were caught in a
powerful current and dragged far
offshore the greek coast guard was
notified and after a search the men were
declared lost at sea but ivan got lucky
as he was drifting he spotted a soccer
ball bobbing in the waves and grabbed it
he clung to the ball for 18 hours before
being spotted by a greek air force
helicopter and a rescue operation was
launched it turns out the owners of the
ball recognized it in greek news
coverage of the rescue it belongs to two
little boys who lost it in the waves 10
days before while playing on a beach
some 130 kilometers from where ivan was
found
one of the other men who was washed away
was also found safe while the third is
still missing
and that is global national for this
friday i'm nitu garcia tonight's your
canada is this pod of pelicans in the
heritage hills wetlands in sherwood park
alberta thanks for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow
[Music]
you